research finds that we put a lot of
mental focus onto gestures so for
example if I were to say today I want to
talk to you about five big ideas but
hold up the number three your brain is
more likely to believe my gesture just
try right now just say five but hold up
three ready five five five is horrible
right does your brain hurt the reason
for that is because our brain really
likes to be congruent with our gestures
as viewers they know that highly
competent people know their content so
well they can speak to you on two tracks
they can speak to you with their words
but can also speak to you with their
gestures or their hands which increases
retention and also increases
memorability